call it download page squeeze page a
landing page call it whatever you want
this is the page that takes unknown
people and transforms them into known
users and we at future we have a ton of
these pages and we're gonna be honest
they all stock
[Music]
when I first stood our website up in the
future I needed to get things up and
running really really quickly within a
matter of weeks
so I customized the stock beam that I
bought online and threw up a really
really quick before it press website now
over time the site has been added on to
it's been patched it's been fixed it's
been broken and to be honest it's really
time to pay this site some some
attention it's time to show our digital
homes love basically what it boils down
to is we have outgrown what we have so
we're going to cover this overhaul this
complete site overhaul really in-depth
on this channel but but before we get to
that I am revamping all of our inbound
marketing stuff and the first thing on
the list is to revamp our download pages
so I'm gonna take you guys through my
process of redesigning a single web page
this process is quick it's easy it's
down-to-earth and you guys can take my
tactics and my approach and apply it to
your work pretty much immediately this
is going to be a multi-part series but
today I want to cover basic user
experience design and wire framing
there's a lot of different ways to skin
this cat there's there's a lot of
different ways to design user
experiences but every single time I
always start off in the sketchbook now
before drawing anything I like to figure
out a few things I just write a simple
list on one side of the page and I look
for answers to four prompts now these
prompts are our goals the user goals
questions to answer and emotions to
invoke now to answer these prompts I
just jot down three or four bullet
points under each one this does not have
to be fancy especially if this is your
first pass at the page I always say that
the first asset at a website is always
an educated guess it's okay to guess
just make it an educated guess once I
have all my bullet points mapped out I
start sketching a basic wireframe the
question always comes up what comes
first
well the thing that comes first is an
intersecting goal if you have a goal
that both your users need to accomplish
and your website needs to accomplish
from
a business perspective or the site
owners perspective that intersecting
goal should always be represented first
on a website in our case the goal is to
get a download the users are coming to
this page because they want to download
something for free and we want to drive
those conversions so I'm gonna
prioritize the form above everything
else and that's the first thing that
goes on the page I also want to make
sure that there's an easy-to-read
summary on the page just in case there
are those people out there who don't
read I don't know you're out there now
once that first goal is accomplished I
want to start filling in content that
fills in and answers the rest of the
questions and the rest of the goals in
our case this is educating the users you
guys on what this download is and what
you get we also want to make sure that
we're answering all of the users
questions or what we're guessing the
user would ask it's also really helpful
to make sure that you keep in mind what
assets you have at your disposal now
assets are images videos illustrations
the creative things that make the
website pop and I know that we just
finished shooting a promotional trailer
for this download by the way this
download is the first meeting worksheet
it's a fantastic resource to send
magenta for that first meeting with the
client which I got who's the link go
check that out so because I know that we
shot that video I know that I need to
use it I wanna make sure that I have
space for that video on the page now
remember you can put anything you want
on this wireframe anything any idea that
bubbles up in your head but you want to
make sure that you remember that
somebody has to make this stuff you know
throwing 97 images on a webpage might
not be the most effective use of your
time so you want to keep that in mind
make sure that you have those assets
kind of in your head as you're putting
them down on the paper now I know that I
have this video but I also know that I
want to do a couple of new mock-ups for
this template and so I'm gonna make
space for those images in that video I
also know that I want to make this
diagram that shows the process of making
a sale and where this kind of fits in in
the process so because I know that I
want to make that stuff I want to make
sure that
the page long story short don't go crazy
with photos and videos if you don't have
them make sure that you're using the
assets that you have or that you can
make my life is dying here now there are
you symbols that I use all the time
larger headers are written out if I can
think or brainstorm of a really catchy
title smaller headers are there these
like narrow rectangles that are really
wide and short and then text is usually
just straight lines that are grouped
together videos looks like a box with a
play button inside it's pretty
self-explanatory and then images it's
another box except this time it has a
big X across it I mean you guys get the
idea you can kind of see the site come
together in the sketch you just want to
make sure that you're using the same
symbols so that later on down the road
when you're looking at this thing four
months later and somebody asks you hey
well what's supposed to go there you
actually have an answer once I have all
the content mapped out on the page I go
back to my list and I make sure that
every goal and question has been
answered I literally go through and
start checking things off and labeling
these sections on my wireframe this
doesn't have to be pretty this is not a
showcase of your sketching abilities
this is just a rough sketch the
wireframe of a potential webpage that
you're redesigning so just work fast and
efficient and get your thoughts on paper
as quickly as you can that's why I love
starting in the sketchbook because of
the sketchbook this is where creativity
is born and you just don't get that same
feeling that same vibe that same freedom
from working on a computer and I've done
it a whole bunch of different ways with
those wire framing kids throwing my own
wireframe I use the mobile apps for wire
framing and nothing compares to pencil
and paper so once I'm happy with the
basic wire frame in a sketchbook
now it's time to take it over to the
computer next time we're gonna cover how
to create a digital wire frame in a
program like Adobe XD if you have any
questions or want me to do a deeper dive
of anything that I covered in this video
please let me know in the comments
section below I cannot
to read that stuff I love when you guys
interact and I'll be stocking the
comments for a few weeks months hours
days as always guys I want you to go out
there and crush it you got this like
subscribe we love you we'll see you next
time
oh and by the way by the way turn on
that little Bell notification this is a
new channel and I don't want you guys to
miss any part of this series so make
sure that you're subscribed make sure
that you hit that Bell so that way you
get notified when new videos pop up and
you don't miss a second of this
thrilling website we'll see you next
time